Dwain lead Chapman better known as Dog
the Bounty Hunter
made a name for himself by bringing
criminals to justice while urging them
to change their ways the tanned and
mullet topped reality television star
nabbed fugitives and scored major
ratings for over a decade before pretty
much disappearing from the airwaves but
dog hasn't been locked in a kennel this
legend of Liberty has remained active
across the American frontier here's what
he's been up to for the last few years
uncaged cage according to ABC News New
Orleans police arrested actor Nicolas
Cage in 2011 after a domestic dispute
with his wife Alice Kim got a little out
of hand
dog a fan of cages later bailed him out
of jail
charges against cage were dropped later
that year and we're still waiting for
someone to make a TV series out of this
burgeoning friendship arrest warrant for
Beth in 2013 doc and his wife Beth
Chapman's vacation in Colorado was
interrupted by a loud car according to
TMZ Beth shouted insults of one of the
passengers before calling the police and
leaving before officers arrived the
teenager suffered no consequences but
calling a person names is actually a
crime in Colorado
one passenger filed a harassment
complaint against Beth when she didn't
pick up the summons police issued a
warrant for her arrest she later turned
herself in saving dog from the awkward
task of bringing his own wife to justice
dog talked about his time in prison in
2015
dog revealed that in 1976 he was charged
and convicted of the murder of an
alleged pimp and drug dealer the dog's
friend pulled the trigger while he was
waiting in the car
Chapman received a five-year prison
sentence ultimately serving 18 months
years later Chapman dealt with the
incident during an episode of dog and
Beth on the Hans third season to show
people it's possible to turn your life
around
stepdaughter arrested for bank robbery
according to Hawaii news now dogs
stepdaughter Nicole Gillespie allegedly
robbed the downtown Honolulu territorial
Savings Bank in 2015 upon learning of
her arrest dog issued a statement
revealing that Nicole had been estranged
from the rest of the family for some
time it's always difficult and
disheartening when someone you knew as a
child grows up and chooses a life of
crime we've not seen Nicki in over ten
years watching her on Crimestoppers lets
us all shocked and heartbroken ended his
show to save bounty-hunting
Chapman ended his three season follow-up
show for CMT dog and Beth on the hunt in
2015
saying he wanted to combat bail reform
efforts across America calls for reform
started after a rash of unfortunate
incidents like a man being shot to death
by bounty hunters in Idaho according to
in touch dog felt his energy was better
spent working to stop proposed laws that
included establishing requirements such
as minimum age limits for bounty hunters
and licenses to carry concealed weapons
and things are going dogs way in 2016
according to the Idaho press Tribune his
efforts helped defeat such a bill in
Idaho almost one year after the death of
the affirmation man he imposed his Stand
Your Ground laws during an interview
with HuffPost live dog voiced his
opinions on the sensitive topic of gun
control first he sought to debunk the
gun lobby's argument that the only thing
that can stop a bad guy with a gun is a
good guy with the gun he insisted he's
never used a gun on any of the criminals
he's caught because tasers and pepper
spray he also argued that so-called
Stand Your Ground laws are bullcrap not
the opinions you'd expect to hear out of
a guy who looks like Chapman or one in
his line of work just goes to show you
can't judge a book by it's cover or a
bounty hunter by his mullet cultural
impact if you've watched this video to
this point because you know all about
our friend Dawg and recognize him as
more than just a bounty hunter with
beautiful hair that's because in the
years since he first took the television
he's become more than just a strong man
bringing people to justice he's become a
cultural icon a real-life Boba Fett he's
been referenced in shows like American
Dad Family Guy and South Park I'm gonna
show as huge as The Simpsons makes
reference to you you know your legacy is
secure thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to see more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know if you want to
see dog back on TV